bonsoir tout ceci n'est que très
superficielle ça manque de profondeur
on reste en surface vous connaissez ces
expressions au québec on dirait c'est
donc bien plate en fait dans notre
expression nous expressions quotidiennes
les surfaces sont associés à des notions
négative à des sujets très ennuyeux et
non pas très bonne presse
donc ce soir j'aimerais vous parler
d'une surface ultime qu'on appelle le
graphène et essayer de voir comment elle
essaie de tirer son épingle du jeu au
milieu de tout ça alors de quoi parlons
nous nous parlons d'un matériau à base
uniquement d'atomes de carbone organisé
dans un réseau hexagonal comme des nids
d'abeilles et ce matériau a une
particularité unique c'est de ne faire
qu'un seul atome d'épaisseur et toutes
ses propriétés vont découler de cette
particularité et c'est ce qui explique
qu'en fait le graphène au lieu de
ressembler à ces nids d'abeilles qu'on
verra bientôt ressemblent en pratique
plutôt à un véritable essaim d'abeilles
qui se jette sur le graphène
littéralement qui sont des abeilles et
chercheuse des abeilles industrieuse
d'une frénésie complète autour de ce
matériau tout le monde s'agite et très
excité à l'idée de trouver les nouvelles
propriétés qu'on pourrait éventuellement
utilisés dans des dispositifs alors vous
pouvez pas profiter de cette belle image
je vais essayer de vous expliquer donc
avec les mains comment ça se présente le
graphène
donc c'est exactement comme les nids
d'abeilles on imagine des hexagones
formé uniquement d'atomes de carbone et
au départ ce graphène c'était une
véritable gageure des théoriciens avait
prédit qu'une structure planaire
monoatomique ne pouvait pas être stables
dans des conditions standards et que
plutôt que de se présenter sous forme
d'un feuillet elle se présenterait sous
forme d'une boule de papier repliée sur
elle-même pour retrouver une structure
3d qui elle serait stable
mais comme l'écrivait l'écrivain mark
twain il ne savait pas que c'était
impossible alors ils l'ont fait des
chercheurs se sont attelés à ce problème
et ont réussi à réaliser ce graphène un
peuple hisser mais attention à l'échelle
nanométrique
mais stable dans nos conditions alors
comment ont-ils réussi ça tout commence
en 1985
quand des chercheurs ont réussi pour la
première fois avec uniquement des atomes
de carbone a réalisé une molécule qui se
replie sur elle-même avec exactement la
même structure qu'un ballon de football
et cette structure sphérique stabilise
les situer la situation de la molécule
qui devient stable à partir de là pour
la première fois il existe une molécule
qui définit un espace clos dans le pen
dans lequel on peut venir piéger des
atomes ou des molécules uniques et ça
leur a valu le prix nobel
quelques années plus tard au début des
années 90 la structure cette fois en nid
d'abeille hexagonal repliée sur elle
même pour faire un cylindre a été
réalisé et cette forme de cylindre
stabilise la molécule pour faire un
nanotube de carbone
enfin le carbone en nid d'abeille
bidimensionnel vous le connaissez vous
en faites l'expérience tous les jours
dans vos mines de crayon sous forme de
graphite
cette fois chaque feuille de d2 carbone
sont empilées les unes sur les autres et
c'est le fait qu elles interagissent les
unes avec les autres qui les stabilise
cet empilement les stabilise et réalise
ce cristal de graphite
alors comment ces chercheurs qui ont
obtenu le prix nobel en isolant une
seule couche de graphène ont réussi à
l'extraire de ce cristal de graphite
et bien tout simplement avec un rouleau
de scotch en prenant un morceau de
scotch un petit cristal de graphite
ils sont venus le mettre sur le christ
de le rouleau de scotch et en arrachant
les feuillets les uns après les autres
comme ils sont empilés comme un
millefeuille ils ont réussi à les
extraire les uns après les autres à
affiner le matériau jusqu'à obtenir une
seule couche atomique qu'ils ont réussi
à reporter sur un substrat pour faire
des dispositifs pour montrer les
propriétés uniques de ce matériau et
c'est cela qui leur a valu le prix nobel
alors très bien
à partir de cela toutes les propriétés
ont découlé elles sont très nombreuses
et elles sont même trop nombreuses vous
pourriez le voir mais je ne vais pas
vous les listes et parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup trop
donc ce soir je voulais insister sur
seulement trois d'entre elles à savoir
que le graphène est transparent
conducteur et flexible
transparent conducteur et flexi vous
allez me dire il ya rien de très
excitant à tout ça on en voit plein des
matériaux conducteurs ou des matériaux
transparents qu'est ce qui l'attiré
original l'originalité ici vient du fait
et je vous mets au défi d'en trouver
beaucoup qui réussissent ce challenge
c'est de réunir les trois propriétés en
un seul et même matériau il est
conducteur est transparent et flexible
et ça c'est pas tout le monde qui arrive
conducteur il est comme le graphite
parce qu'en fait un plan 2d de graphène
est une véritable patinoire à électrons
qui vont pouvoir glisser sur la surface
et réaliser ce qu'on appelle une merde
électrons libres qui sont capables de
transporter le courant électrique dans
les matériaux conducteurs vous
connaissez la plupart sont opaques
ici le graphène arrive à devenir
transparent car quand un matériau
conducteur est affinée et devient
suffisamment fins ils n'arrivent plus à
bloquer toute la lumière
si vous prenez un disque compact et que
vous le mettez devant une source de
lumière vous serez capable de voir le
filament de l'an poule où la lumière de
la bougie ou la diode
électroluminescente qui sera placée
derrière comme vous le voyez sur cette
merveilleuse image et c'est pour cette
même raison
alors le graphène lui il n'a qu'un atome
d'épaisseur donc pas question pouvoir
bloquer toute la lumière
il est transparent exactement à 97,7 %
et c'est pour cette même raison qu'il
est aussi flexible si vous prenez un
matériau et que vous la fim et comme du
film alimentaire
il n'a plus le volume nécessaire pour
résister à la flexion et vous obtenez un
matériau très flexible donc le graphène
est également flexible donc avec ces
trois propriétés le graphène a les
éléments de base pour faire une belle
histoire à savoir pour faire une belle
histoire il faut de la matière des
classiques et de l' aventure pour ce qui
est la matière le graphène est un
nouveau matériau qu'on est capable
maintenant de synthétisé en laboratoire
sans rouleau de scotch et ce jusqu'à des
surfaces des mètres carrés et sur les
machines industrielles même des
rotatives sur des rouleaux entier des
centaines de mètres de longueur de
rouleau mais pour contrôler son
épaisseur d'un atome
ça reste très délicat à réussir la
plupart du temps on obtient ce que vous
voyez à gauche à savoir des petits
défauts des patchs de bi couche et de
tri couche qui viennent casser cette
uniformité du matériau nous avons
développé un procédé qui permet le
complètement supprimée
et patchs de multicouches et d'avoir un
matériau strictement monoatomique sur
des grandes surfaces et une fois qu'on a
ce matériau on peut leur porter sur un
support alors les supports qu'on aime
bien en général ce sont ceux qui sont à
la base de toutes nos technologies à
savoir les plaques de silicium ou de
saphir mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres
qu'on peut imaginer
donc on a ici la matière première pour
les technologies au passage et ça c'est
un point qui est vraiment un rêve pour
un physicien c'est que vous voyez sur
cette image que même si les monos
atomique ce matériau quand on le reporte
sur une plaque de silicium ou sur du
verre on est capable de le voir à l'oeil
nu
pas besoin de microscope ou d'appareils
13 est sophistiqué on le voit à l'oeil
nu comme sur ces photographies et ça
c'est assez assez émouvant de pouvoir
imaginer voir une couche monoatomique
donc à partir de ce matin de cette
matière première qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va commencer par revoir nos
classiques et le premier classique
incontournable c'est le transistor
donc on peut fabriquer des transistors à
base de graphène vous en avez un ici et
ce jusqu'à détail macroscopique
attention le transistor en graphène n'a
pas les mêmes propriétés que les
transistors en silicium qu'on a dans nos
ordinateurs donc c'est pas tout à fait
la même histoire mais puisqu'il est
transparent on va pouvoir aussi imaginer
faire des électrodes transparente à
gauche vous avez l'image d'une diode
bleue électroluminescente sur laquelle
on est venus déposer des feuillets de
graphène qui permet d'injecter le
courant dans la diode pour la faire
briller et qui a le bon goût d'être
transparent pour laisser sortir la
lumière qui vient de la job
sinon ce serait s'il était opaque ce
serait complètement impossible
d'imaginer faire des écrans tactiles en
graphène
comme vous voyez ici à l'écran on peut
aussi revoir un bon vieux classique
cette bonne vieille ampoule à
incandescence si on remplace ce filament
de tungstène d'une ampoule à
incandescence et qu'on la remplace par
des rubans de graphène elle en passant
un courant dans le graphène on va
pouvoir le chauffer jusqu'à ce qu'ils
émettent de la lumière et se
suffisamment fort pour réaliser un
éclairage avec en plus la propriété de
le faire avec une puissance électrique
moindre et une durabilité plus grande
que dans le cas de diode
électroluminescente très bien on est
capable de mixer nos sens nos standards
mais ça n'est pas assez
les laboratoires sont plaints de
créatifs qui n'ont plus envie c'est de
jusqu'où on pourrait aller et c'est là
que revient le couplage de nous trois
propriétés
puisque le graphène est flexible
conducteur et transparent si on le met
sur un polymère flexible et seulement
transparent on va pouvoir avoir un
matériau comme vous le voyez sur ce film
que l'on peut déformer à loisir mais qui
reste conducteur ici quelques kilos mme
est donc avec ce nouveau type de
matériau s'ouvre nouveaux domaines qui
commence juste à poindre le bout de son
nez à savoir l'électronique flexible
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière
l'électronique flexible et bien par
exemple
fini les téléphones portables qui
cassent en tombant par terre à cause des
électrodes transparente qui sont
friables et cassante comme celles qui
sont utilisées actuellement on va
pouvoir imaginer des matériaux plus
souple plus résistant aux chocs et qui
vont pouvoir également s'adapter mieux à
notre ergonomie ce à d'adopter d'autres
d'autres formes plus adapté à notre
usage quotidien
la question que nous nous sommes posée
c'est très bien jusqu'où est ce qu'on va
pouvoir pousser ce cet effet de
flexibilité nous avons poussé le vice au
laboratoire jeu jusqu'à soumettre le
graphène à des substrats
particulièrement agressif comme celui
que vous voyez là avec des piliers de
silicium donc très fin très pointu sur
lesquels on est venu déposer une feuille
de graphène est là ce qui est étonnant
c'est qu'il ya deux façons de réagir
pour le graphène si ces piliers sont
suffisamment espacées il va se déformer
se suivre le profil et être capable sans
se déchirer de recouvrir parfaitement la
surface des piliers de la base au sommet
et d'adopter le profil complètement
tridimensionnelle du substrat qu'on lui
qu'on lui propose al'inverse si on
rapproche les piliers et de façon
contrôlée
le graphène va commencer à ne plus
vouloir épouser la surface on va pouvoir
fabriquer des tentes sur la surface dans
des directions contrôler si maintenant
on met des piliers très proche
alors le graphène on va pouvoir le
garder complètement plat suspendu sur
pilotis et ce sur des surfaces très
grande complètement déconnecté de son
substrat et là ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on
arrive à libérer le graphène de son
substrat est elle à avoir une couche
monoatomique suspendu soit sur des
pilotis soit complètement suspendue sur
des trous comme vous voyez ici où on a
réalisé un genre de peau de tambour qui
va être capable de se déformer étanche
ase et aux molécules donc mois pour
appliquer des pressions pour la déformer
ou des champ électrostatique et déformer
la surface d'où notre peau de tambour
pour des applications à des capteurs
très sensible faire des nems sont
d'autres types de dispositifs arriver
cette étape de l'exposé vous commencez à
vous dire ça y est on va nous vendre
encore un matériau super héros qui va
sauver la planète
non le graphène n'est pas un super héros
qui va sauver la planète
ce que j'aimerais pointé du doigt c'est
qu'il est pionnier dans son domaine et
qu'il sait jouer collectif parce qu'à
partir du moment où les chercheurs ont
réussi à isoler un feuillets de graphène
pourquoi ne pas faire pareil avec
d'autres matériaux en feuillets c'est ce
qui s'est passé tout le monde a pris son
rouleau de scotch et s'est mis à
exfolier tout ce qui passait et il ya
toute une famille de nouveaux matériaux
qu'on appelle les matériaux 2d qui est
qui a vu le jour avec des matériaux qui
conducteur qui isolants ou alors actif
dans le but d'enlever dans le visible ou
dans l'infrarouge ou bien un
supraconducteur avec une résistance
parfaitement nul et à partir de toutes
ces possibilités
on peut cela était proposé dans ses
dents dans cet exemple on peut utiliser
chacun de ces matériaux comme une brique
lego et venir les superposer les uns aux
autres et refabriquer le matériau
feuilleter idéal pour une application
donnée c'est ce qui a été fait ici dans
cet exemple de manchester où ils sont
venus utilisé trois de ces matériaux
pour faire un sandwich de luxe les uns
sur les autres et réaliser une diode
électroluminescente avec du graphène
pour injecter le courant dans la diode
est un matériau aux petits cons actifs
capables de recombiner les charges
électriques et maîtres de la lumière est
ici vous avez une image de la diode qui
est en train de briller sur la droite
donc on va pouvoir à partir de ces
dispositifs imaginer toutes sortes
d'applications en empilant ces matériaux
2d et on voit à 7 dans cet exemple que
tout se joue à la surface à la surface
de ces matériaux pourquoi
tout simplement parce que ces matériaux
ne sont que des surfaces ce sont des
surfaces ultime qui n'ont pas de volume
et n'ayant pas de volume
elles sont ouvertes sur le monde est
prête à interagir avec tout leur
environnement
si l'on contrôle l'environnement va
pouvoir contrôler ces interactions et
jouer un peu plus loin avec des
matériaux plus petit que les matériaux
devait on a commencé avec par exemple
des neurones ici vous avez un transistor
graphène sur lequel on est venu faire
pousser des neurones il se trouve que le
graphène est biocompatible mais plus que
ça le graphène est très très
accueillants pour les neurones c'est à
dire que les neurones vont préférer
poussé sur le graphène plutôt que sur le
verre qui est juste à côté
et donc on va les laisser pousser
s'installer ils sont bien moelleux sur
leurs transistors au graphène ils vont
commencer leur activité de neurones
l'activité du neurone est une activité
électrique et le transistor en graphène
lui est sensible à l'activité électrique
et on a deux en un une ainsi un support
idéal pour faire croître les neurones et
qui en plus est capable de détecter
l'activité de ces mêmes neurones
l'activité électrique
donc on va avoir des sondes de
l'activité neuronale
allons plus loin et plus petit le
graphène s'intéresse aussi à plus petit
que lui
et si cette fois on décore ce transistor
en graphène avec des petites molécules d
porphyrines qui sont impliqués dans la
photosynthèse dans les plantes
ces molécules sont trop petites pour
qu'on puisse facilement les étudier une
par une ou les connecter à des
électrodes mettons-les sur du graphène
qui lui est beaucoup plus facile à
manipuler ces molécules impliquées dans
la photosynthèse sont sensibles à un
signal lumineux
elles vont capter la lumière et être
excité par cette lumière cette
excitation en fait va pouvoir être
transmis au graphène sous forme de
charge électrique et donc on va pouvoir
transférer un signal lumineux en un
signal électrique et ce qu'on voit c'est
quand on soumet ce système à de la
lumière on à la résistance électrique
globale du système qui diminue et qui ré
augmente quand on revient dans le noir
dans le même ordre d'idée si cette fois
en le décor avec des nanoparticules
supraconductrice c'est-à-dire un
matériau fissile est un un matériau qui
va pouvoir à basse température voir une
résistance
eq te ment nul et donc aucune perte de
chaleur par par le courant est bien ce
matériau qui n'est pas capable d'être
utilisé pour faire un transistor va être
couplé au graphène est ce juste sur
détails très grande et on va pouvoir
juste en appliquant une tension sur le
dispositif passer d'un fonctionnement de
transistors de type métallique standard
normal on dit à un transistor de type
supraconducteurs où il n'y aura aucune
perte de chaleur à cause du courant
électrique donc ce qu'on voit dans ces
différents exemples c'est que en
assemblant ensemble et matériaux on peut
avoir un ensemble qui vaut plus que la
somme de ses parties et j'aimerais
insister sur le fait que le graphène
n'est pas une fin en lui il a des
propriétés certes très intéressant mais
ce qui est le plus intéressant c'est pas
ce que lui seul est capable de donner
mais plutôt qu'ils nous ouvrent la voie
à réaliser de nouvelles plateformes des
plates formes pour les interactions
comme un échiquier
on va pouvoir placer des objets sur la
surface qui vont interagir entre elles
et avec le matériau pour réaliser des
nouveaux dispositifs avec des propriétés
couple et entre elles et j'aimerais
insister sur le fait que ce mix de
matériaux est très important et
notamment en nanosciences parce qu'on a
nos sciences comme dans la vie la
diversité apporte beaucoup de richesses
je vous remercie